bienvenue au café des tempi la renommée
des desserts italien servi ici dépasse
les frontières du quartier heureusement
notre spécialité en fesses et les
parties civiles
mais on est en plus secrètement vigueur
dans le sens qu'on la fedpol formé à
l'institut de tourisme et d'hôtellerie
du québec isabelle a travaillé dans le
réputé restaurant avant d'ouvrir ce qu'a
fait il y a deux ans alors cannoli
oranges confites peut-être chocolat
c'est la mode est à petit la wii les
canalise j'ai testé j'ai essayé j'en ai
même peur parce que je réussissais pas
mais je tenais en enfer parce que je me
disais ça peut pas être si compliqué que
ça rentre des liens marie-michelle aussi
s'est donné comme défi de cuisiner ses
desserts son produit animal faire une
chaîne comment on devient spécialiste de
desserts végétales y ait beaucoup de
prat et on commence à en fait parfois
des recettes à prouver on trouve sur
internet pour la majorité
on les teste puis après on peut se
réapproprier le serpent petite bosse et
on veut qu'ils ont travaillé à partir
d'elle selon nos deux pâtissière ce
n'est pas si sorcier de remplacer les
aliments d'origine animale
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
le but de negredo dans une recette que
c'est à partir de là qu'on arrive à à
transformer se prendre une recette qui
est pavée gagner leur en vigueur
[Musique]
niveau des camps grotte coucou l'huile
d'olive les huiles en général le beurre
de cacao aussi que j'utilise beaucoup on
va voir par exemple la plv gan qui est
identique vegan parce que la majorité
des margarines ne le sont pas même si on
avance à croire qu'elles sont
végétalienne la majorité contiennent de
la poudre de lait il existe aussi sur le
marché des tartinades végétalienne plus
ferme très utile en pâtissent
donc son report l'utiliser si on a un
besoin de glace en bordeaux par exemple
qu'on a besoin de factures sas a regardé
une bonne texture pour tenir un gâteau
pour substituer le les vaches plusieurs
options
côté des gt alors notre lait d'avoine
les tuyaux les dry lait d'amande lait de
cajou du lait de noisette du méchant
pour remplacer les yeux maintenant les
yeux c'est souvent les grisons qui a un
but très spécifique dans le reste se
dépasser on peut remplacer avec
différentes secure on peut remplacer
avec farine ou même tous les produits à
base d'algues comme la gare agha
c'est une gélatine végétal qui est fait
à partir d'une algue comme par exemple
dans la partie seront remplies fin venir
côté j'ai la tenue s'affiche super bien
au tout vécu pour remplacer les yeux
dans un gâteau diluer dans l'eau des
graines de lin moulues
[Musique]
et sur cet art aux citrons non ce ne
sont pas des blancs deux montés en neige
notre pote de pois chiches dans le tas
non on va utiliser la copa barry et
l'eau qu'on jette habituellement dans
une conserves de pois chiche qu'on va
monter en neige avec de l'extrait de la
nuit puis un petit coup de gomme de
xanthane pour faire la morale
c'est le plus gros développement en
partie civile italienne dans les
dernières années je dirais la coiffe à
bord ça se lit ce super bien dans les
biscuits libres et remis son une recette
qu'on aime puis on veut juste changer
les yeux pour la ronde et vegan et oui
ça serait bien
on a la preuve ward quand même qui au
goût curieuse c'est surtout cela qui m
on peut pas savoir savoir que c'est pas
d assez vrai myton chocolat c'est la
cofa bas je mets un peu de soupe de
beurre puis du chocolat au final c'est
comme si on avait mangé un morceau de
tablettes de chocolat lui rien de
meilleur pour la santé les desserts
vegan mais il ya quand même de l'huile
dans mon gâteau il ya quand même plein
de trucs à l'intérieur c'est pas un
gâteau au super santé mais physiquement
ça va juste être fin produit animal
parce que tout se fait en pâtisserie aux
végétaliens tous fait est-ce que tout se
fait déjà là maintenant non je pense
qu'il y comme beaucoup de tests à faire
beaucoup de recherches au niveau des
ingrédients des textures des goûts au
début la gamme de produits c'était très
bruns des puces créer des machines des
choses comme ça qui en faisant un peu de
recherche
on a réussi à développer quelque chose
de commercial
[Musique]